looks like a who dressing room it does
look
speaking of which yeah i mean uh i just
told you backstage but
uh i was interested in being a musician
when i was a kid i was so into the who
and uh i mean you guys were my group for
quite a while there when i was growing
up and
you hear so many legends about your
group most of which was about being
banned from hotel rooms you guys pretty
much started that
getting kicked out of hotels can you get
one now wouldn't you
well i'm just curious i mean here you
are in new york city can you get a hotel
room now do they book you
they loved us the hotels they didn't at
first
the the gun the uh cherry bombs were not
popular
because they used to destroy toilets
usually with someone sitting on them
because keith moon had this uh in
invention of
uh of he'd like the cherry bomb and he'd
work out
the timing on the fuse and he'd work out
how many stories it could flush down the
toilet
and what floor it would explode on
so that he could never be blamed and he
actually blew
someone up on a toilet once
and they didn't like that but but after
that um
they suddenly sussed out that they could
redecorate their hotels so the navarro
hotel which was
then became the ritz carlton um i think
we redecorated that whole hotel
because because you guys would pay you
guys would have to pay for the damage
and when they let they say who are
coming in next week which room do we
need redecorating
right and they would put us in the
rotten room right and we'd trash it and
then pay for it to be redacted and
everyone would just stay off the toilet
while you were there pretty much
did uh the holiday inn banned didn't
aren't you guys is that a lifetime ban
from the holiday inn chain
yes they did us that favor very early on
um
so you can never i mean i can never
thank you i mean i've never heard of a
lifetime
ban from like and especially holiday inn
it's supposed to be like we welcome you
with open arms
yes lifetime ban you so have you ever
tried the lincoln continental in the
swimming pool
that was like yeah we've heard that of
course it was on the third floor which
made it rather difficult to get out
was keith moon the one that drove it
into the swimming pool okay so he had
decided i got to graduate from dropping
cherry bombs into a toilet
what's next hey i know lincoln
continental in a third floor swimming
pool and
it happened to be brand new lincoln
continental in swimming pool
third floor on his 21st birthday wow
bill to the band which is nearly fifty
thousand dollars more than we are on the
whole tour
well because you guys were constantly i
mean you're famous for you'd always
smash your instruments at the end of the
show
you had to pay for that yep so you
weren't earning money for quite a while
there were
a long long time a long that's why i'm
still working
[Laughter]
down the road doing 15 shows a week you
know but it was great
i mean we had that we had so much fun i
can't tell you it was
just one wonderful time i always wanted
to ask you about the
uh the outfit that you wore at woodstock
when the who played woodstock you're
wearing something that looks just like
you went through a paper shredder
just before you went on stage and i was
always wondering was that was that a
wardrobe that you bought somewhere
what happened i mean that one was that
was uh some friends of mine used to work
in leather
and i had this suit made up with all the
fringes and then i beaded the back and
that
and that lasted like everybody thinks
that rockstars have loads of clothes
well i've never had loads of clothes i
mean i've kind of got what i stand up in
and this is it you have pretty much it
falls off yeah and falls apart this is
all hemp by the way
if i can't smell it i don't need to know
where you're going i can't smoke it i'll
wear it you know
so uh um can we borrow your jacket would
you like
two
[Applause]
and uh that that suit i actually have
made but it lasted for
for the whole of the tommy touring
period which was about two years
by the time i finished with it it could
actually that suit could almost do the
show on its own
it was a living organism yeah then i
graduated and
i went on to making the clothes out of
car chamois leathers
and i would kind of sew them together
punch holes in them and sew them
together and
what what's the chamois leather i don't
know look at the shelves
i thought you meant you took the
upholstery from car seats
because that's a great idea for a new
rock band but it was a great look
and uh i'm curious about are you
incorporating any of the stuff that you
made famous
as the lead singer for the who into your
scrooge persona
i'm wondering is is there any point in
the show where you do the scream from
won't get fooled again or something
i play i kind of feel that i'm at the
beginning of the show i'm playing
a rock and roll manager someone who's
very mean and wicked and
can uh frighten the hell out of
everybody you've clearly had some bad
experiences
well i think everybody has
but it's a wonderful part to play uh
most people think it's a
story just about an old mean guy it's
much much more than that it's
it's the reasons why it became mean and
he's he's such a huge
character to play right and uh we tell
the story in 90 minutes
it's a wonderful show i'm sorry but
nothing from your who dave's has been
worked in you don't
at the end grab tiny tim's crutch and
smash it
something i've been tempted
no i i actually do sing
i refuse to sing broadway so i kind of
bend the notes
here and there why because you don't
want to sound like you've gone broadway
not really ethel murmur man you know you
know it's not i've always thought of you
as that so i kind of
uh but i and it but it works it kind of
works it's
it's dangerous to do it the way i'm
doing it are you there's flying
in this show that's something that i
don't think you ever did in your days
with the who you never did anything
where suddenly because a lot of rock
bands now they they put the harness on
and the guy flies up over the crowd
i think tommy lee plays his drums
suspended around the crowd
sometimes oh i've seen him in the video
i'm sorry no is that something else um
he was suspended on something anyway
[Laughter]
um uh oh
roger what uh
are you flying the show yes you have to
wear this kind of harness
which is very precariously placed and
when you're getting dressed well
it kind of goes up here and around here
and it's all got
lumps and straps and it's very s m yeah
yeah
they kind of get it it's the same it's
the s m scrooge yeah
certainly well it certainly is if you
put the strap in the wrong place
and you don't realize it till it's going
up
then you come down and you could sing
with the beach boys for the rest of your
life
hey great i'd love to hear you sing a
who classic after that experience i
think it needs to get a whole new sound
in the band
oh landy what a load of olandy that
would be
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i'll go see that show whenever you want
to do it uh well a christmas carol
is uh at the theater at madison square
garden
yes if you can find it they'll find
there is a theater
underneath the garden that is there
believe it or not
it's hard to find though you kind of
need a a a root map
because maybe you should put a sign out
on the spot complaining about it all the
time i know i think i'll go out on the
street with a bell and say
theaters here yeah we'll do that for you
it's uh it's at the theater at madison
square garden that's through december
27th and uh
roger uh it's it's really great to meet
you you know it's crazy
thanks for doing it roger daltrey
everybody we'll take a break
we'll be right back